To say that Koreans love kimchi is to make a startling understatement.
The spicy vegetable dish usually made of fermented cabbage, red peppers, and garlic...
...takes up entire sections of grocery stores.
Traveling businessmen carry it abroad in their suitcases for fear of doing without.
And any student of history knows that clay pots full of this stuff...
...kept the Korean people alive for centuries during harsh winter seasons.
So, when South Koreans prepared to send astronaut Yi So-yeon to the International Space Station...
...for at least ten days, some asked whether any Korean could manage without Kimchi for that long.
Kim Sung-soo is a senior engineer at the Korea Food Research Institute near Seoul.
For him, the answer to that question is clear.
Yi So-yeon will not survive in space without kimchi.
Koreans need to eat kimchi every day in order to sustain their health.
She'll have all kinds of problems in space without it.
But Kim points out taking kimchi into orbit is no simple matter.
The dish gets much of its flavor and nutritional value from fermentation.
That age-old bacterial process that makes bread rise and gives beer its bubbles...
...can create a series of dangers in a tightly controlled environment of a space voyage.
Kim has spent most of the last two years in a laboratory making kimchi ready for space.
His team starts by irradiating and slightly cooking regular kimchi to reduce bacteria.
Then the dish is frozen and rapidly dehydrated in giant appliances in an industrial facility next door.
Finally, it is cut into little cubes that look like biscuits ---
then, vacuum sealed into plastic bags.
Astronauts can cut right into the bags and add water, rehydrating the cabbage and spices.
Then, it is ready to eat right out of the plastic.
Very good.